foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
the
the Tony Michaels podcast real and raw
political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
Grandpa all ranty pants
well did he break his bond I don't know
I don't know does it really matter if he
did or not
will there be consequences
for Donald Trump to threaten Democrats
on Jerusalem I doubt it
I don't think so
I mean there's no consequences in this
two-tiered Trump justice system anyways
he's bitching this morning
on true social
fraud and social that the doj and FBI
has been helping Joe Biden in his
campaign effort
it's all projection of course
continued projection they're like ah
political persecution with the doj and
the FBI def fund defund the police Mike
is literally what they're saying to fund
the police they're giving it a
weaponized government they're going to
weaponize Governor they're going to
weaponize our Congress to try to defund
the FBI and the doj
because they're Prosecuting uh Trump for
crimes that he committed
I mean this isn't rocket science
and the more we go on about this
the more I want everyone to understand
exactly what is happening here
and the history of which in which
context it is happening
this is fascism 101.
When Donald Trump is being
indicted and convicted in a court by a
jury of his peers listen Joe Biden did
not prosecute anyone
Joe Biden
has the ability
to nominate an attorney general
okay
that's one piece of our democracy
so Joe Biden has the ability to
to nominate an attorney general
once that happens the attorney general
just doesn't have free reign once Joe
Biden's like up Merrick Garland you're
the Attorney General see what happens in
our democracy is that the Senate then
confirms that cabinet member
so our government our government We the
People select our Senators
to make sure that the president we
selected
nominates someone for these cabinet
positions attorney general in this case
to be worthy
and eligible
and give the consent of our
Representatives the senators of our
state
you see how that that's how it works now
in the case of Donald Trump and I can't
believe I have to do this kindergarten
type
I can't believe I have to do this
kindergarten type
explanation of how this stuff works
but it's getting worse and worse and
worse as it goes along because the more
Grandpa ranty pants Grandpa poopy pants
the Cheeto dust Q anoner continues
to attack our Democratic institutions
the more I feel like I have to do this
kindergarten type explanation
so once Merrick Garland is the attorney
general
and the former president enough evidence
has come to light that holy [__] the guy
tried to overturn our government over
trying to turn the election any
committed felonies oh [__]
American appoints a special counsel
which then is distances the Attorney
General from the investigation
that is ongoing
now that special counsel then adjourns
two grand juries two of them
two of them
average citizens one in South Florida
one in Washington D.C
presents the evidence and the charges
to the grand jury and they vote to
indict in both cases
it's not Biden
okay
and really honestly this whole Biden is
a mastermind of using the doj and the
FBI as a political apparatus to help him
win his campaign I thought you
[__] didn't even think this guy
could tie his shoes
you can't have it always it's not all
the it's not all of the things
it's more whining it's more bitching now
I want to talk about
um court dates
a little bit more uh
again you're probably not going to like
some of the things I'm gonna say
to the audience out there that is
pro-democracy and listens to
more left leaning type media but they're
not liberal media
and they're sensationalizing and they're
saying things to make you feel good and
I was listening to some legal analysis
on on the on the television yesterday
and I say listening because I wasn't
watching I was listening
I don't watch TV I listen to it
I don't need to watch it to hear the
commentary
here's the thing
they were spot on oh man they were spot
on
spot on about
what has happened in the last few weeks
with these legal cases against Donald
Trump
and then at the very end at the very end
the very end someone who should have
enough [__] idea of what is
real
and possible on MSNBC Glenn kirschner
again
and I I know you I know you guys like
him I know you like his analysis and
really Glenn's a smart guy I don't know
why he does this I have no clue why he
does this actually you know what I think
I do know why
and this this is going to hurt
the pro-democracy Coalition folks
I'm I'm telling you this because I see
trouble
in the future
with this idea
and the reason why I've said for months
and months and months and months
that Donald Trump will not go to trial
in 2024 is because it is a real
possibility
that he won't you think oh no no no
they're saying he will but it is a real
possibility that he will not
that is worst case scenario and we need
to operate in that space
this narrative that the doj
prosecutors rather it or judges whether
it be chutkin rather it be the Manhattan
D.A rather it be funny Willis in Fulton
County they are not going to save our
democracy folks
you cannot count on them saving our
democracy
this is not their job
and every time I listen to this
commentary it continues with this same
stupid [__] narrative that they're
going to
and the hope is there that the
prosecutors will save our debt is not
their job
it is not the judge's job or the
prosecutor's job to save our entire
democracy
their job is to prosecute crimes that
are committed within their jurisdictions
the judge are to oversee and preside
over the court proceedings
of the Criminal prosecutions
that are brought before their bench that
is their job
our job as Citizens
our job is the pro-democracy Coalition
who still believes in democracy in this
country it is our job
to save democracy it is us we are the
Democracy we are the people we are the
government
why do you think these [__] boneheads
are buying Trump's arguments about the
doj and the FBI being weaponized against
him
it's because the narrative from some on
the left
is that oh yeah the doj's Gonna Save Us
the courts Are Gonna Save Us they're not
it's not their job it's not the design
to save our democracy it never was
intended to be that way
and the more we capitulate to this idea
the worse it's going to get and the more
trouble we can have ourselves in
I don't know if I have to explain the
danger
of trumpism taking reins of power in
this country I don't know if I have to
explain that or not maybe I do maybe I
have to go to the extent to explain what
the dangers are
and why it is so important
in this country that people understand
what the danger is
and that we can't sit back sip our sip
our Kool-Aid
and count on someone else saving this
country
the battleground of the ballot is no
more clear than now
and that's where this war of
misinformation and lies
should be fought
is at The Ballot Box
and we can keep doing it
we can keep on and keep on and keep on
having every single ballot
are every single Battle At The Ballot
Box
it would be my [__] pleasure
but you're not going to win democracy
in a [__] courtroom
that's that's the arm of Justice
and there's so much more to our country
than just Justice
there's so much more to this story
there's so much more to our future than
one person being on trial folks
there is more to our nation's history
there is more to our nation's future
than just this one [__] box
being on criminal trial
and with the possibility because I I
know it feels good because you're like
oh March 4th he's gonna go to trial Tony
it's already set
I I get it I get it I get what you're
saying but also the same [__]
the same [__] that are saying
that [__] that are convincing you that
it's a damn it's a slam dunk for March
4th they were the ones that promised you
you they would get cameras in the
federal courtroom
how'd that turn out for you huh
huh
how'd that [__] turn out for you
same [__] said uh no way will
Donald Trump ever be able to be the
nominee if he's indicted in four
different jurisdictions on 91 felonies
same [__]
huh how that how is that working out for
you
how's it working out for you
I'm telling you
when he says the [__] like oh they're
coming after you I'm just standing in
their way he means he's coming after us
the Democracy We the People he's coming
after us
the same as DeSantis is in Florida
the same is the same as Greg Abbott is
in Texas
folks
do you have any idea do you have any
idea the risk of fascism when it takes
hold
do you have any idea how hard it is to
unwind fascism
and do you have any idea the links that
they will go to keep it in place
I don't know if you have met a religious
zealot before
a 21 year old
white male
try to go kill some people
Jacksonville at historical black college
and then proceeded to go to a Dollar
General
and assassinate
because it's a political assassination
folks I don't give a [__] how you turn
it
goes to assassinate three black people
in a Dollar General
plans were authorted at the HBC so you
know next best thing make a political
statement
where do you think he got the idea of
swastikas on his gun huh
where where do you think he got do you
think he got it from the from the Nazi
that the pro DeSantis Nazis that protest
in front of Walt Disney huh you think
that's where they where he got his idea
where do you think DeSantis got the
ideas that he's that he's putting in
Florida
do you think Ron DeSantis pretended to
be Donald Trump for four [__] years
on accident
I know I know you're mad at me when I S
when I speak out against the left or I
speak out against someone who oh they
should know what they're talking about
well if they know what they're talking
about then they should not be telling
people that the justice department that
the courts are going to save our
democracy
because they're not
they're not going to
let me give you a little dose of [__]
reality here is a possibility that this
[__] box will not see a criminal trial
until after the election
there is a good possibility oh no Tony
there's yes there is a good possibility
of that
if you're not um a student of the dumb
[__]
and the and the the art of delay in
court with Donald Trump I guaran God
damn to you come January February next
year Laro his attorney
who is going to represent him on March
4th where they have jury selection which
it'll probably be pushed to June or July
by then
so maybe maybe it'll be May
depending on when it's pushed
Laro is gonna be fired
he's gonna switch counsel that's what
he's gonna do
and he can do it and he will do it
and do you know what Chuck can will do
she's gonna piss you off oh it's gonna
piss you off
and she said it the other day she said
it with her own words
that Donald Trump is allowed a defense
he's going to he's gonna show Laro to
the door and get new counsel and the new
Council will be afforded time and effort
to put together a defense for Donald
Trump pushing the trial again
I know you're like no no no she's not
gonna put up with that [__] I don't care
what you say I don't care what you don't
know what I do know is that Donald Trump
is gonna go to the end of the Earth to
become king of the United States
he's gonna try and do anything he
possibly can
because it's his only savior
that's the only way he saves his ass
that's it period
Jim Jordan can't save his ass that's
clear even though they're weaponizing
the government against a duly elected
County prosecutor in Fulton County and
the Manhattan DA's office and trying to
defund the FBI and the doj because
they're Prosecuting criminal Republicans
because all of a sudden in our [__]
political body the Republicans just
can't stop committing political crime
folks I know it doesn't feel good to say
these things but it is what we need to
come to grips with
we have we have to get right with the
truth
and the truth is is that it's going to
be a long long time before Donald Trump
sees the inside of a prison cell if he
ever does
that's the hard [__] truth and you
may not like it
you may not like it I'm not here to tell
you things that you you're gonna like
I'm not here to tell you that [__] I'm
not here to fluff you that's not what
I'm here to do
and it will never it will never be what
I do is fluff you
and the cold hard facts are
that Donald Trump is on his way to
accountability
but we cannot let that accountability
whenever and whatever it may be in the
future stop us from holding him
accountable at The Ballot Box
going to be the nominee Chris Christie
doesn't even get it I listen to a clip
of Chris Christie on MSNBC this morning
talking about how we need to convince
Republicans
we need to convince Republicans that
someone who's a convicted felon
shouldn't be the president of the United
States
Chris why are you out trying to convince
Republicans of [__] they've already
decided
they've already decided this [__] just
like you just like you who are mad at me
about speaking out against legal
analysis that are a bunch of hooey
it's hooey it's [__] Huey I don't
care how you shake it just wait just
wait I was right about the [__]
cameras in the courtroom I was [__]
right about it
I was [__] right
they've shut their mouths remember it's
two weeks cameras cameras cameras
cameras cameras and all the camera
people have shut their [__] mouths
haven't they
about cameras because it ain't a [__]
thing
it could be though Tony oh it could be
he could go to trial March 4th yeah but
he's not going to
get [__] real
no what is real and what is your [__]
fantasy
don't drink the [__] Kool-Aid this is
no time to drink Kool-Aid on this issue
we must stay vigilant we must know
how we are going to save our democracy
and a lot of people don't like what I'm
saying I get it
but it doesn't mean it doesn't need to
be said
the ability to save our democracy is in
our hands
not in shutkin's hands not in funny
Willis's hands not in a federal judge
somewhere listen to Mark Meadow's
[__] down in Georgia trying to flip
his trial from a state courtroom to a
federal one folks they're not they are
not going to save your [__] Nation
they are not going to save your
democracy they're not gonna do it
you are
and I again I know I'm gonna get [__]
hate comments I'm gonna get all kinds of
[__] I'm gonna get link sent to me
I get it every time I do this I do I
[__] when I went on the tirade about the
cameras people like Jesus Christ Tony
why are you talking about cameras here
here's a link here look the Democrats
are writing a strongly worded letter
the [__] out of here
again get [__] real stop drinking
Kool-Aid stop it
this is no time
to let your guard down
your way of life is at risk this
country's freedom and liberty is at risk
I know we got a lot of [__] issues to
deal with holy [__] you talk about a lot
of policy issues that need to be fixed
in this country I don't know if you've
been watching what's going on in
Tennessee but God damn I haven't had
that chance to get to that story
and it ain't because I don't want to
talk about that story
they're stripping democracy away from
Tennessee
centering people on the floor
because they speak their minds because
they tell the truth and fascists don't
like the [__] truth
well when you stop when you start being
scared of the truth too you need to look
deep down inside you
Florida
is a road map for a fascist State Texas
is their road map for a fascist State
Tennessee is their road map to a fascist
State and they're knocking on our
[__] door
it's no time to rely on one [__]
judge
one politician one prosecutor
one appointed attorney general to save
us
and the more that language [__] seeps
out into the minds of Americans
the more trouble we're gonna be in next
year
and I'm gonna keep yelling and screaming
it
I know Glenn I've watched him for a long
time hell I've been I've been on screen
with Glenn
I've asked Glenn a lot of questions
before on screen on air
he knows his [__]
he was a damn good prosecutor
he says a lot of the stuff that is that
is true
but his posture
that a prosecutor and I get it because
he was one a prosecutor and the
courtroom can save our nation is a bunch
of [__] [__]
what happens when he goes to trial on
March let's just say let's just play
this out March 4th he goes to trial they
select a jury in one week
and all we're on our way to saving
democracy what happens when he's
acquitted oh but Tony that's not a
positive it is a possibility
do you not understand how jury trials
work
there is no slam dunk here
other than you
fighting the battle where it must be
fought
at the ballot
making sure that these [__] fascists
don't touch our democracy is more
important now than any [__] court
case that is going to happen next year
you understand that right
no matter what any legal analysis tells
you
I don't give a [__] about the trials
I don't give a [__] about this motion or
that motion
none of it matters none of it matters
if we don't fight the battle that needs
to be fought at the ballot
none of it matters
not a goddamn single shred of it
and I'm not gonna stop saying it because
it's the truth
go look at your [__] history book
they [__] put Hitler in prison
for trying to commit a coup
and how'd that work out
I'm telling you
you can't stop fighting
at The Ballot Box
[__] the courts [__] these criminal
cases yes I understand we need to
politicize the [__] out of him but [__]
the Republicans can't even muster up
enough courage
to figure out a way to get rid of this
[__] idiot
and as long as their cowardice remains
he remains
in our crawl
no matter what one judge says or does
our date that they sit
it's time for us the pro-democracy
coalition
to rise above the absolute [__] and
do our job
and make sure that this next election
is the most important election of our
nation's lifetime
and what these [__] fascist up
and dump them in the [__] trash
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
welcome back to the show are you mad at
me yet
[Music]
I don't know maybe or not maybe you're
on the same wingly tonight as I am I
think you are more than you're not to be
quite honest again I I listen I listen
to these legal analysis and I agree with
about
98 of what they say but the direction of
their narrative
um when they're like oh yeah the judge
will save you don't worry chetkin's
Gonna Save Us all is again it's not the
truth and it's not it's not a a message
that is going to resonate throughout the
country and if it does resonate
throughout the country and she doesn't
save us then what the [__] are you gonna
do
yeah it may be too late
we have to work our answers off this
entire time from now until the next one
and then when that one's over like 2022
got over you we got to go to the [__]
next one because these fascists are not
going to go away after this next
election [__] Donald Trump even after
he's dead and gone maybe he chokes on a
Big Mac and dies before he hits the
ground we can only hope
what do you want from me
but even even when he's dead and gone
they're still gonna be flying Trump
Flags
they're still gonna fly Trump Flags
they're still I've [__] there's some
people that still think JFK Jr's still
alive
you don't think they're gonna they I
showed you a lady yes Jade thanks Donald
Trump
is the president and Military has been
in power since 2016.
it's a disease folks it's a [__]
disease fascism is a goddamn societal
disease
and Trump is not is not the [__]
disease that's the [__] symptom
of the disease
and there's no there's no real cure for
it there's no cure
that idea of fascism it's out there
it exists and as long as ideas exist you
can't get rid of them
you can't burn enough books to get rid
of fascism
just like you can't burn enough books to
get rid of the truth you can't you can't
act like history that doesn't exist or
that does exist doesn't exist to get rid
of it it's not a thing
it's hard to do that that's why they've
lost the culture wars that's why they're
so [__] pissed
they're pissed because it's gonna take a
lot for fascism
to really take control in this country
because we are standing in their way
when he says that [__] oh they're after
you I'm just standing in their way he's
projecting
he's coming after democracy is his
[__] enemy
Justice is his [__] enemy Liberty is
his [__] Liberty of the people is his
[__] enemy
that's why he's freaking out
on fraud social
telling to the Democrats I say
be careful what you wish for
bring it on [__] bring it on
[__]
I don't have to we don't have to fight
him in a courtroom we can fight him
in the realm of the ballot
that's where we can invite him
[__] his courtroom
let his supporters continue to to fund
his is not his pretend billionaire ass
with his attorneys
just keep it going it's Tuesday Tuesday
Tuesday taco Tuesday Texas Paul Tuesday
we have Texas Paul here waiting in the
wings I just want to tell you what you
should do right now is use subscribe to
the YouTube channel rather you hate when
I say or you like what I say you can't
stop watching they love me or they love
to hate me
it's fine by me either way I'm good to
go
so don't forget to hit that subscribe
button go to thetonymichaels.com all the
links are there get in on the
conversation over on Discord follow us
on Facebook uh find us on Twitch over
there
and also if you want to drop a venmo
super chat you can find that link on the
Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com Texas Paul he probably
hated what I said this morning too Texas
Paul welcome welcome
no I loved it man I really do yeah I
mean you know I I you know a lot of
people a lot of people don't like when I
I attack the lab but I'm not attacking
the left I'm attacking the narrative
that is gonna hurt us that's what I'm
attacking that that's that's all it is
it's not it's not anyone a personal
Vendetta against anyone it's just I
don't like the narratives that are going
to expose us to the threat of fascism
that's all I'm concerned about
I mean it's right on the money and the
audience will tell you I mean the
audience will tell you this is not like
2016 when the right wing could push out
of some some [__] narratives and
everybody will just go along with it and
you know everybody's watching corporate
media and you know all they have to do
is say something outlandish and
corporate media is like
let me put that on there so that
everybody will keep their eyes on the
screen like they're reading the freaking
tabloid
and yeah the judges aren't going to save
you folks everybody's figured that out
they know they've got to get to the damn
Ballot Box every election every time we
got election coming up this November I'm
telling you man I am fired up for this
Tony I am I am really 100 I've taken a
couple months where I've kind of slowed
my role a little bit you know just got
everything fired you know got my ducks
in a row got where I'm going with this
and I am telling you man I'm coming out
guns blazing for this election it is all
about reaching gen Z all about reaching
the Millennials that aren't voting yet
it's all about getting those what the
hell went wrong with the freaking gen
xers I don't know we came out saying hey
we're not going to be like our Boomer
dads and then turn around half people
turn around and turned right into their
Boomer freaking dads right down to
wearing goddamn flip-flops with the
goddamn socks on man I just it's
no no we're gonna do this brother we are
going to do this and everybody knows
everybody that hears our voice knows
they've heard it a hundred times and
they're going to hear it ten thousand
more times before the election you've
got to get your ass in the hole in in
the voting booth that's the only way
this is that's how democracy Democratic
Wars are fought
that is what the gift of democracy is to
you we get to go to war with each other
without killing each other get your ass
in the in the voting booth be a good
soldier let's do it let's get it done
well I want to show you because I
mentioned the um the tennis what's
happening in Tennessee because if people
aren't watching and paying attention
what's happening in Tennessee
um Cameron Sexton that [__] pile of
trash down there and the speaker uh down
there he's the one who uh led the
Crusade that that expelled uh Justin
Jones
um and his colleague
from the house now Justin Jones is back
in the news because he wouldn't let
Justin Jones speak yesterday he actually
censored him on the floor
um and the Dems walk down oh and [__]
that's not that's not right let's see
here let's I'm gonna show you a video
here of it now if I can get my [__]
together here
um here is here's a video of it and this
is this is what they want
When Donald Trump says dims
what you wish for he means dims be
careful we're going to Outlaw that you
can be a Democrat that's what that's
what he means you're not going to be
able to be a Democrat because they're
like oh well we can't be Republicans
it's illegal to be Republicans which is
so far from the [__] truth it's not
even funny
but this idea is that they want to
Outlaw being a Democrat but watch this
here Davidson County has plenty of
Representatives in this body let us
decide for our County and speak for our
County instead of forcing the will of
the super majority on a county that has
already been mistreated and maligned Sr
roles have not been shown to reduce
instances of mass shootings instead what
we've seen are disparities in terms of
expulsion of students of color students
with disabilities we've seen increased
instances of students trafficked into
the criminal justice system what our
schools need are mental health
professionals we need funding for mental
health for counselors we need to pay our
teachers better we don't need more
police in our schools representative
Jones you're off the bill again sir
you're out of order oh that's two I'm
sorry we're on the board that's the
second time being out of order today for
being off the bill there's no point of
voice non debatable we're on the board
are you saying that we're voting if
members thought that the member was off
subject 90 of the individuals in here
wasn't listening to him number one can
you tell me what he said because I'm
sure you heard it that was ruled out of
order so I can know how to vote I do not
have a transcription it was ruled out of
order it's non-debatable and the second
time you're ruled out of order it's a
vote of the body I know this member has
delivered something to my letter to
everyone's office representative Powell
you're under parliamentary inquiry not a
speech on the house floor sir I heard
the word debates or remarks so I want to
know how the clerk is taking this that
this member can no longer make emotion
or present legislation that he has been
elected to give problem here is that you
have the discretion to say what is it
isn't out of order a previous
representative bullso was ruled out of
order twice by the speaker for two
comments and no vote was had clerk why
didn't we have a vote for representative
bullso Mr Speaker it was my
understanding at the time that it was
just a warning because the member was
allowed to continue the speaker directly
said out of order
not in
not is my understanding that
that was a non-debatable issue
and it seems to me that we're
entertaining debate that's the end of it
Mr clerk take the vote
Mr Clark take the vote the galleries
rolled out of order
I-70 20 days Department of Safety please
clear the balcony for disorderly
Behavior
and it passes
Troopers please clear the balcony
oh
and you see that it erupted out in the
hallway now what is happening here
here's what happened
um Justin Jones was trying to make
points towards the bill that was be done
and because he tried to silence Jones
called for no confidence vote in speaker
Sexton that's when speaker Sexton
silenced him for the rest of the day
it's also when the balcony erupted and
um Cameron Sexton doesn't like democracy
and he definitely doesn't like to be
called a fascist because he is one um
that's when he exited the people
observing their democracy in the balcony
and then they took to the hallways as
the Democrats left the chamber
um Texas Paul this is uh not only is it
a image into what the Republicans want
in these State houses but it is an image
of what they want in our federal
government where they do not want any
opposition they just don't want it
fascism does not afford um the right for
opposition it doesn't and that the
reason why is because they don't believe
in Freedom Liberty or rights
um and this is a road map along with
Florida but more like in Tennessee with
their Congress there with speaker Sexton
Kremlin Kremlin Cameron as they call him
um this is a road map to what they want
in our United States Congress
absolutely absolutely you look at what
uh you know death scientists is doing
down in Florida uh you know removing
legitimately elected Democratic
prosecutors that have done nothing wrong
um just one thing after another after
another these people are showing that
they don't believe in democracy and and
little inside baseball there Tony uh
representative Jones Justin Jones was
going to introduce a vote of no
confidence on speaker Sexton right
that's why he zeroed in on Jones that is
why he absolutely made sure that and and
it wasn't an out of cut it wasn't an
off-bill statement the bill was about
schools it was about dealing with
security in schools he said instead of
wasting money on unnecessary security
measures which is
debate over the bill we have other needs
in our schools that need to be addressed
that is perfectly in line debate with
that bill you know I mean it
he intentionally did this to prevent a
vote of no confidence in himself because
I mean he knew it was it it didn't stand
a chance of passing because of the
Republican majority
but it was going to be one hell of a
party line vote it was going to be and
you probably had two Republicans that
were going to flip
that were that were going to vote for
that vote of no confidence because of
this special session and the way it's
been handled I tell you man these these
Republicans do not believe in democracy
they do not believe and and they always
say well we don't have a democracy we
have a republic well damn it you don't
believe in a republic either
I mean look at this this is this is
Republican representation Justin Jones
was elected to represent his district
you don't believe in that either so just
sit down shut the hell up Let the
grown-ups in the Democratic party take
care of things and we'll make everything
okay
here is that from Gloria Johnson now you
remember Gloria Johnson was joined by
Justin Jones and Justin Pearson when
they were expelled she was the only one
of the three that was not expelled
because she's a white woman
um that I'm just gonna say it out loud
because that's the [__] truth they
expelled uh Justin Jones and Justin
Pearson because they're black and
they're men they're black men that's why
they expelled them um and they
definitely don't like the opinions of
black men in Tennessee and by they I
mean the Republicans now but here's
Gloria Johnson's explanation of what
happened uh there yesterday
hi friends I'm sure several of you have
already heard Democrats walked out
walked off the house floor tonight as
our undemocratic speaker once again shut
down our youngest black member
representative Justin Jones called him
out of order twice
and took a boat to silence him for the
rest of the day
however another member a republican was
also called out of order twice tonight
no vote was taken to silence that member
for the rest of the night that didn't
happen
okay so if you didn't catch that what
she's saying is is that there was a vote
to silence the black man the Democrat
who is a black man but the Republican
who is out of order not vote to it no no
no vote no vote to silence them because
it seems it seems as if it seems as if
Kremlin Cameron Sexton
has a vendetta against uh representative
Jones I wonder what it could be I really
wonder what it could be we know what it
is Cameron Sexton you're a [__]
racist that's what it is you're a
[__] racist and you are you are a
weak little man who cannot take someone
else's opinion because your own power
has gone to your [__] fascist little
head that's my I guess that's my two
cents to Cameron Sexton what do you make
of it Texas ball
and I think you're spot on Sexton's a
jackass he knew that that vote of no
confidence was coming he didn't want it
he didn't so you know two sets of rules
you know Tennessee Republican right-wing
jackass
uh white guy doesn't you know get held
accountable but you know hey we're gonna
apply the rules that don't really apply
in this situation you know it's it's
like a damn bogus traffic stop man yeah
do I smell something you know I mean
it's just same [__]
gonna invent something to hurt this
person you know because he is black
because he you know I I can get away
with it in Tennessee because there's a
lot of piece of crap Republican
right-wing trash voters so I can get
away with publicly doing this on camera
where everybody can see it because I'm
garbage and my voters are garbage
this is what the Republicans want
nationally this is what they're
clamoring for nationally they're they're
not embarrassed they're not embarrassed
by Cameron Sexton they love that Cameron
Sexton's doing this they're cheering
that Cameron Sexton is so so I uh we've
been posting some shorts on YouTube and
I did a short the other day
um skip over on Discord has been helping
cut this the clips and he caught one
where I was talking about Ron DeSantis
and I was talking about Rhonda Santos is
at his end of his political career he's
ruining his political career I said
nothing about the actual policies in the
clip I said nothing about the actual
policies that Ron DeSantis uh was
specifically putting in place of Lord
not all the egregious [__] that he's
done uh to black people the lgbtq
community other other marginalized
communities in Florida Banning books
getting rid of curriculum I mean there's
on and on and on it goes about around
desantis's uh the evidence of his
fascism but some someone came in the
comments and and said that I was
let me think about this they said I must
be a gay teacher who is upset that that
it can't be groomers anymore I said
nothing about teachers I said nothing
about education I said nothing about
children I said nothing about the
policies that that Rhonda Santos was
doing in Lord I just said he was
destroying Florida
and it's just the projection right
because it's not it's not because Rhonda
Santos is Republican that these [__]
[__] boxes love him
they love Ron DeSantis because he is a
fascist
that's what they [__] love they love
Donald Trump because he's willing to be
as fascist as they need him to be
these [__] Republicans in Tennessee
love Cameron Sexton because he uses his
power to oppress representative Jones
that's what he does
without with without without
accountability like you're saying
because they're not going to hold him
accountable because they like what he's
doing they like the two-tier system they
like that one white Republican can be
held out of order but not be voted to
silence but the black man you goddamn
right vote to silence them immediately
they love that they're cheering it on
which means folks which means the threat
to our democracy is not always
necessarily the people with power it's
the people who put them in power
people get mad at me when I'm like let's
make them self-suppressed press their
vote
um someone's asking on Discord if I'm
talking about Shaz from yesterday no
this is a totally other this totally
different troll uh Shaz is gone I had to
I had to kick Shaz because she has
crossed the line and and kill all the
trolls out there listen we want to keep
you around we want to have fun with you
but don't cross that line or I'll kick
you because this is because on this show
in my chats it's not a democracy [__] I
have the chats they're my chats and I
get I get to say what happens in my Jets
whether you like it or not that's my
freedom of speech not yours if you want
your freedom of speech go get your own
[__] show and do your own [__]
thing over there but you're allowed to
be here you're allowed to exist as a
troll I don't mind your opinions when
you start saying bigoted ass [__] Nazi
ass [__] and start attacking people in
the chat I've had enough so
um but Texas Paul
um I really do believe that Cameron
Sexton is allowed to do this not because
Cameron Sexton isn't being watched It's
because Cameron Sexton is being cheered
by his Republican base
yeah absolutely I mean you hit it right
on the damn head man I mean you nailed
it oh you got to forgive me I got a bit
of a migraine today so I wouldn't wear a
hat but oh I see hair keeps bothering me
keeps falling in my face
um sorry about that but no Cameron
Sexton
that that's exactly it that's all they
have left is this pretend to be powerful
thing that that's it you know Cameron
Sexton really has no power I mean he he
doesn't he's a weak vile little man just
like just like that troll coming that
that was saying that [__] about you oh
yeah it's just a [__] he's he's a shitty
weak little person who couldn't build
anything if he tried he couldn't build
an organization if he tried hey this is
going to come out and just try to run
his mouth and pretend like he's somebody
and puff his chest out and then and he's
nobody they're trash
Republicans have done nothing they have
nothing to stand on nothing whatsoever
their entire existence in government is
I'm addict to Democrats
that's what I do I'm addicted Democrats
own numbers love me for that don't you
love me for that and they do love them
for that because Republican voters are
just as much worthless useless trash
as Republican politicians
they don't care about our government
Tony they don't care that our government
has to function that our government has
a job
all they want to do is is talk shitty to
people and and and have somebody tell
them they're special you're so special
you're you're you're so important you're
the Cornerstone of our country you are
you and your little small town
with
shitty water and no electricity you're
just special right as we as we take away
your as we try it we vote down uh rural
high-speed internet we vote down
infrastructure for Rural communities we
vote uh here's another one I don't know
if you know this but this morning this
morning it is announced for the first
time ever ever in our history
Medicare now has the authority to
negotiate prescription drug prices I
don't know if you know that I don't know
if folks know that that now it's not
going to come as fast as everyone needs
it or wants for them to come with the
prescription drug uh prices to be to be
done but this is thanks to the inflation
reduction act uh that this is going to
happen and this is going to provide
people on Medicare uh relief from high
ridiculously high prescription drug
prices here's what's going to happen
Texas ball
and um you know sometimes I I uh you
know cringe at Democrats as they're
horrible at doing this but they always
do it now they did it with the
infrastructure Bill where that now
Biden's pretty good at this going to
these uh ground breakings and saying hey
I'm the one who delivered this check the
guy who's trying to take credit for it
voted against it you [__] dummies
um but here's the thing is that when
this happens over the next couple years
because it's gonna it's gonna take a
couple years for this to go into effect
to really negotiate it's going to take
almost a year to negotiate these prices
and then for them to go into effect
you're really looking at 2026 probably
for for the economy really to see this
effect and that's that's the thing that
it's going to be for is for the economy
I mean I don't know if you folks
understand this but when when people
have money they they tend to spend more
money right
so here's the thing when these drug
prices get lowered in 2026 because it's
going to be long forgotten after the
election
um Republicans are going to be like yeah
see we we've lowered drug prices with
Medicare we love doing that the
government we we the Republicans help do
get the Medicare and the drug prices to
where a year and you should vote for me
even though they voted against the
inflation reduction act just like they
voted against the infrastructure act and
they want to pass out [__]
infrastructure checks just like they're
gonna uh for weeks and weeks and months
and months and months to come they're
going to be taking credit for rule
broadband and they didn't want it they
didn't want it they voted against it not
only did they not want it they voted
against it and then they're going to go
act like they're going to sell this [__]
and that's who these [__] are
that's who they are and that's what
they're going to do and we must fight
against their message and their
narrative
that's all I'm saying
um but what do you make of the
prescription drug thing tell me what
what do you make of this do you think
Democrats are failing there's a
messaging of this
no no it's out all over social media
today I'm very proud of them for getting
out there ahead of it and um you're
getting a lot of people that are
responding well yeah but my drugs not on
that list my you know it's going to take
x amount of time before this kicks in
and you know just that seems to be the
response by a lot of people and my
answer to that is [__] Republicans
if we Democrats had been able to put the
bill through we wanted to put through it
would have been carte blanche across the
board negotiate on all drugs immediately
the reason it doesn't work that way is
Republicans because they're trash
garbage human beings
that represent farmer bro billionaires
that that's what they do they're not
decent human beings they don't look at
your average person is getting buried
under Med under under the cost of their
medicines they don't see it they don't
care that's not who they represent
that's not who they're there for they're
there for freaking farmer bro that's who
they're there for and that's who they
represent so that this bill while it's a
good thing and we're proving it we're we
are proving it Democrats you give us
power this is what we do we are fighting
we don't have enough power yet to just
push through our agenda give us the damn
power get to the voting booth give us
the power to do the right thing we're
proving it to you this bill is proof
we're negotiating the cost of drugs to
bring your drug prices down because they
are insanely High it shouldn't be a
thousand twenty five hundred dollars a
month and more just to stay alive
you know it just to have the medication
you need
to have a a decent night life
[__] Republicans but shouldn't that [__]
them all to hell but shouldn't that be
the messaging out front instead of yay
with these 10 drug prices are going to
go down it's like well we got 10 drug
prices but we don't have all of them
because of these [__] boxes if you
wanted all your drugs to go down it you
should vote these [__] boxes out see
Democrats do that a lot they like to run
laps but they forget they forget to tell
the people why the [__] that they can't
run the lamp as fast as you want they
always forget this right they're always
like yeah yeah patting themselves in the
back look we got these 10 drugs that are
negotiated and it's a it's a huge
Monumental uh movement uh in Medicare
where we can now we are now on the brink
of Medicare negotiating drug prices uh
in this way
and it's just the first set of these
select drugs but again the mess there
you go
there's there's the appropriate
messaging
um for the drug prices by the way my cat
loves your hat loves your hat dude I
cannot keep her off your hat it's a good
hand she absolutely loves this freaking
hat everywhere I put it she finds it and
lays on it man it's a good hand it's a
good hand um but here's here's the uh
here's the drugs the list of drugs and
you'll have to forgive me because I
probably aren't gonna pronounce any of
these right but these are listed the 10
drugs
um that the White House has announced
this morning that they're going to be
able to start negotiations over the next
year and that's the other thing too is
that Democrats uh their messaging on
this is going to be horrible because it
always is I believe that it is is that
over the next year they're gonna have to
negotiate these things so they're going
to continue to get stupid ass questions
and they're gonna give stupid ass
answers uh to why they don't have the
American people's uh drug prices lowered
yet
um even though it's on the way and the
only reason why it's on the way is
exactly what you said despite
Republicans like that nothing nothing
that Republicans did lowered these 10
drug prices they actually would want to
do the opposite to the American people
um and it's it's crazy because what they
also want to do is Medicare and and the
mechanism that they're using to actually
negotiate these prices with Medicare and
to lower these prices for Americans they
want to get rid of Medicare like not
only do they not want these drug prices
not to go down they want to get rid of
the [__] mechanism altogether
to make sure they want to defund the
mechanism altogether to make sure that
the government says no you can't [__]
be charging people that that's some way
you can charge them here's what you can
charge them
um and again it's just the messaging
pure and simple out there man I had
somebody I had somebody comment on my
threads today I put I put a weave out
there about about this exact thing and
they and they came back from the left
that we Democrats aren't doing enough
that her mother's uh Social Security is
only 800 a month
and her uh her medication is over a
thousand dollars a month and we
Democrats aren't doing enough about it
and I you know I I I can't help myself
Tony diarrhea of the mouth you know I
mean I I got a damn migraine today and
I'm a bit salty so I had to tell her
look wait how would you like that
situation if your mother didn't have
[__] Social Security how would you
like that situation if if we Democrats
weren't able to pass anything I mean
we're starting to negotiate on drug
prices but how are you going to like it
when the Republicans get their way and
your thousand dollars a month is now
1900 a month and your mom has to live
with you remember that's what Medicare
did folks you know I know most of
everybody slept through history class
but when they talked about the part
about Medicare it got your mom from
having to live in your house it was
Independence for her
she could live on her own because she
had medical coverage she didn't have to
sell everything and move in with you
just to survive and Republicans don't
care about that they don't care about
your quality of life they don't care
about any of that all they care about is
[__] farmer bro Vivek ramaswamy
wants to be president and this is what
he does this is where he's from he's a
Wall Street turd that started a damn
farmer company
and he's he's just clocking over it he's
not a billionaire yet he's he's
estimated to be worth about 950 million
dollars and and in a couple months he
will clock over one billion dollars in
net worth
and that's who the Republicans represent
hell that's who they are literally now
[__] Pharma bro
so you're saying so you're saying vivec
is more of a billionaire than Donald
Trump because if he's really worth a
billion dollars then he's worth more
than Donald Trump I believe if you
indicted if you indicted vivec you
wouldn't have to go to a bail bondsman
nor nor would he have to beg supporters
to uh pay his [__] legal bills here's
what I'll tell you though about um about
this situation with big Pharma bro uh
Vivek
Ramen suami uh Vivek is uh Andrew Tate
running for president I don't know if
you know that did you know that that
that he is he is the Andrew Tate Bros
running for president that's why that's
why vivec can is going to get away with
a lot of [__] uh as as his Ascension to
the number two because folks I've been
telling you for a while I've been
telling you for a while bevexa plant and
Trump is only going to debate vivec and
here soon here soon Trump will say on
true social on Broad Social he will type
it out vivec is the only one that can
beat him he will say that [__] he will
say that [__] because you know what
they're going to do to vivec they're
going to destroy vivec they're gonna
destroy him and I can't wait for it I
can't wait for it vivec has something in
his past that he can't run away from and
that the right wing will absolutely
destroy him and it's it's gonna be big
it's gonna be big now they don't really
know about it yet and they're kind of
naive to it because they love the vet
because he's saying all the things
Andrew Tate would tell him if Andrew
Tate was running for president
after that's well man they [__] he's
[__] online in sales they love this
[__] oh yeah these [__] crypto Bros
woo yeah crypto [__] Andrew Tate
they're going to expose Vivek ramaswamy
for being a George Soros a sorrow
scholarship recipient
he took Soros money you dumb
[__] he took Soros money like
literally took Soros money
and that's what is gonna happen they're
going that's how they're going to
destroy them they already have it laid
out in the plan that's why vivec tried
to scrub it from the internet
beforehand because he knows that's how
they're gonna destroy him so good luck
to you that I hope you keep going buddy
and honestly yeah I hope you keep
spending a lot of your own money on this
too just just burn that cash let's do it
you know Vivek is going to destroy vivec
that's that's what's going to happen my
impression of Avec ramaswamy folks are
you ready for it here we go all right
burn coal
burn some cow
I mean this guy just says the stupidest
[__] over and over and over again and
and
he he's literally setting himself on the
fire he cannot read a room he cannot
read a room let me go to Iowa do some
rapping you know I mean come on man I
mean did you hear that did you hear the
Eminem son of cease and this is
don't ever do that again don't ever do
that again and I have to tell you Eminem
will punch a [__] in a throat he will
well not only that Eminem Eminem will
come after you not just with his wallet
he will come at you at you with his art
um and he will destroy you with his art
I don't know if you remember this
surrender to Russia
well here's here's the VEC here's 18
year old vivec this this video is
starting to make the rounds you see uh
uh Reverend Al Sharpton here when he was
running for president this is an episode
of Hardball it's a like a a town hall to
help my migraine a little bit man I made
a step off and beat the [__] out of
myself for a minute here's here's here's
vivec 18 years old let's let's listen to
his question to the presidential
candidate question here good Reverend
Sharpton hello I'm Vivek and I want to
ask you last week on the show we had
Senator Kerry and this week and and the
week before we had Senator Edwards and
my question for you is of all the
Democratic candidates out there why
should I vote for the one with the least
political experience whoa ain't that
rich
why the question
the question the question that 18 year
old Vivek wants to know is the question
we should be asking the vet today
that's the question right shouldn't 18
year old vivec be asking uh the back of
today that question you're the least
you're the least experienced Vivek
even even Donald Trump as [__] as a
pretender he is
has more experience now than Vivek Rama
Swami
okay
right there's a I have a legit question
for you obviously you can open your eyes
and see this
Donald Trump has been a grifter his
entire life
so when he wanted to run and he wanted
to sell [__]
he ran a republican told it to you
you just saw the background swapping
talking about he's vote Democrat he's
voting Democrat
which ones you know why should I vote
for one that don't have a lot of
experience I should vote for Joe Biden
you know I mean
when he wanted to run that dude ran a
grift on Wall Street
he started a freaking Griffin Pharma bro
company
and when he wanted to sell [__]
he didn't come to us and try to sell
that [__] because we won't buy it he
went to you
now go take a long [__] look in the
mirror and figure out why these grifters
keep targeting you
you dumbass
uh speaking of dumbasses no I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding uh he gave
Sanchez is waiting in the wings here's
what I'll tell you you know what's funny
you know what's right huh I could give
him [__] you should hear the [__] he
gives me off screen all the time with it
all the time [__] redneck you goddamn
hit no he didn't say anything I'm just
kidding but here's what I tell you
what's funny about this I was wondering
if Gabe was gonna come on and I play a
Vivek Rama Swami clip and Bam there's
Gabe Sanchez it's almost like I summoned
him with the [__] with the [__]
Vivek clip it's almost like it was an
easy summons look maybe that clip will
find its way into the what was that that
I have where I dragged the back Rama
Swami maybe probably could be did you
find this clip is that what you're
saying let me let's watch I didn't I
didn't find this clip I I just someone
else found it um I think on the 18th and
it was just making its rounds yesterday
I see uh I see but yeah it's definitely
gonna
it's well yeah it's definitely gonna
find its way in well well let's listen
to the rest because he just said he just
asked the question why are we should we
elect the least experienced person which
is [__] hilarious that 18 year old
Vivek is on to himself here but let's
let's continue well you shouldn't
because I have the most political
experience
I got involved in the political uh
movement when I was 12 years old and
I've been involved in social policy for
the last 30 years so don't confuse
people that have a job with political
experience uh whoever the head of uh of
of some local bureaucracy has a job in
Cambridge that doesn't mean that they
have political experience and it doesn't
mean they have experience to run the
United States uh government so I think
that we confuse title holders with
political experience as we have uh have
seen with the present occupant in the
way how George Bush was a governor and
clearly has shown he doesn't have
political experience
vivec really likes that answer did you
see that he's like
oh yes yes
you know what's funny about the Vic he
doesn't know [__] about politics
it's not just politics he knows [__]
about history he is a dumb [__] I
remember when he I mean the reason one
of the reasons that Don Lemon ended up
getting his exit out of CNN was right
some part of it related to
the
the conference well you know the debate
but it was really not a debate because
the vet Rama Swami was trying to rewrite
history in terms of the second amendment
being what freed the slaves or what led
to
um
uh citizenship or independence of of of
slavery and it and Donald was like what
the [__] are you talking about dude
that's not at all what it is Second
Amendment the NRA no that's not they did
not play a part in in them not being
enslaved anymore that is not at all a
thing and he's like oh let me tell you
and you got a guy who's running for
president who has no experience in
politics who ran pharmaceutical
companies who ran a shell game
and I'll talk about this in my what was
that but basically Vivek Rama Swami the
way that he runs companies is he would
identify
um the rights or patents on drugs that
big big like uh Pfizer and and uh
AstraZeneca and all these other ones
they would develop a drug like for
Alzheimer's are some of the ones that he
had and they they put in years of r d
and they go well this thing isn't
working so they shelf it right billions
of dollars hundreds of millions if not
billions of dollars they invest into the
development of a drug then they realize
after years they go you know what it's
not working the way that it should we're
going to shelf it but we have the rights
to it Vivek Rama Swami the way that he
ran his pharmaceutical companies it is
he would buy the rights for pennies on
the dollar
restructure them in their own company
and then try to and then and then when
one drug that each would try to Silo off
wasn't successful then he would group it
into another portfolio of Pharma drugs
that he had the guy is moving money from
one company to another I think a couple
of the drugs that he actually had that
he bought the rights to because again
he's not developing the drugs he's
buying the rights to the drugs the
patent and the IP
and so what ends up happening is some
are successful I think maybe two or
three were successful
in its use but then when the
unsuccessful ones aren't getting
traction then he regroups them into a
new company and then he makes a new
company name for them that's all he's
doing he's just moving things around
and they're not he's not actually
developing so what you're saying so what
you're saying is what you're saying is
he's a fraud he's a fraud but the only
reason he knows how to do that is
because he worked on Wall Street and
he's like oh how do I buy up assets and
restructure them right well you know
here's the other thing about Vivek is
what you said earlier like he doesn't
know history and like not even like like
long history he doesn't know Short
History the first time I heard Vivek
ramaswamy speak I knew he was a trump
plant from the [__] first noises that
left his lips on a Twitter space
and one of the things that he said
within the first five minutes of me
listening to him and because I was in
the space I believe either that or you
were in the space one of us was in the
space speaking and Vivek was there the
first time first time I ever heard of
this game first time I ever heard him
speak and I knew he was an Andrew take
crypto bro because oh man Mario was
excited [__] Solomon and the oh they
were all [__] excited about oh yeah
this guy's gonna be great he's gonna be
fantastic he's gonna be the Andrew Tate
of politics get the [__] out of here
because in the in the first five minutes
he starts talking about political
prosecutions and you can't you can't
prosecute former presidents or former
candidates of the presidency and and
someone's like what about John Edwards
[__] Vivek Rama Swami had no idea who
the [__] John Edwards was and had no
idea why John Edwards went to Federal
Court had no [__] clue that's how
that's how uneducated about politics and
our history and just just normal [__]
that happens in our country that Vivek
ramaswami is he's got his head up his
ass and he says all the things that the
crypto Andrew Tate Rose want to hear and
he says it one day and then he says
Another Day a different way here's an
example of that Sean Hannity has to fact
what the [__] is going on Sean Hannity
has to fact check this are you kidding
me we're in we're in a universe where
Sean Hannity okay of Fox News is [__]
having a fact check people in real time
Vivek listen to this
you know you said Aid to Israel our
number one Ally Only democracy in the
region should end in 2028 uh and that
they should be integrated with their
neighbors I have an exact quote you want
me to read it that's actually it is what
he said now he goes on to explain here
his [__] answer because he's like no
no no I was saying if these things
happen then this should happen no no
that's not what you said [__]
that's what you're saying now you're
adding to what you said and the reason
why is because Vivek ramaswamy is Hindu
okay and and he's a sort of scholarship
recipient and and this is Trump the
Trump campaign's plan to destroy him
they're going to prop him up they're
going to make him their second right the
back is the only one that can beat me
it's too bad he's a sorrow scholarship
recipient it's too bad he's not
Christian that's what they're gonna say
that's the [__] they're gonna say about
him and they're gonna destroy him
and along with what Gabe was saying just
a minute ago uh when when Vivek was at
qbt uh and he was on the Pharma desk
heading their their Pharma funds he was
all in for a company called retrofin I
mean that was man that was before he
before he started ravant which is scaled
which is basically a carbon copy of
retrofin
um that's what he was all in on and
retrofin was the name of the company of
Martin [__] shkreli the original
Pharma bro
and that's exactly what
Vivek ramaswamy did to make his money
tell me where's me exactly
where's Martin
oh man don't
I guess that was easy he's in prison
um here's another if you hate Andrew
Mitchell boy you
wait till you hear Vivek and her on the
same screen you'll notice you'll notice
there's a pattern in his appearance with
Caitlin Collins his appearance with Sean
Hannity yeah and or Don Lemon or Don
Lemon but then also on MSNBC every time
they go you said this thing he goes no
no no no no no you're nope that's not
what I said that is not what I said I'll
and then
and he'll he'll do it in this interview
he'll say that's not what I said or
you're misquoting me I can tell you
exactly what I said right now what I
said was and he's trying to reframe this
to be like no no everyone else is lying
which is a trump tactic and he says what
I actually said was this which is
actually not what he originally said and
he's busted and now he's trying to work
his way out of a I mean the the last
week and this week especially
he's getting challenged on the very
merits of what he literally said and
Sean hanny's like I got the literal
quote here man like I can read it out to
you he goes no no you don't need to and
he'll stop them and he goes no I'll re
I'll say exactly what it is and no one
challenges him but watch him do it in
this interview as well yeah well I want
to point out someone's uh fact-checking
Us in real time here about the uh about
Martin I love our audience man yeah
Frank chicken love oh you're gonna love
it you're gonna love this and Rama
scarelli
oh man okay let's watch as as I ca you
know what I can't believe I want this
clip you know what I can't believe about
this clip that Andrew and Mitchell is
still at MSNBC they still put her on the
air that is insanity I don't know how to
wake her up and have her do something
right I guess so I don't know I don't
know I just she's so difficult to listen
to but let's let's take a shot at it
that means you would not have certified
the results that night before midnight
on January 6th while that was your
constitutional obligation what if Kamal
Harris did that what if Joe Biden and
kamela Harris to be clear would she have
that same authority to be clear
but how could you get legislation
through sir in you know that kind of
legislation through in time to certify
the election he would be violating your
oath as Vice there would have been
so I respectfully disagree Andrea I
stand by what I said in that interview
not what you just said that I said I
said that that's exactly what I would
have delivered and then use that as an
opportunity for heroism to reunite this
country because there are two
preconditions for the health of our
constitutional republic one is the
peaceful transition of power the other
is public confidence in our elections
and when those come into conflict that
was a rare opportunity for heroism that
I think Mike Pence missed
um your you and Donald Trump and the
rest of the Republican Party are what
are killing and eroding competence in
elections here's what they're talking
about here they're talking about this
idea that Mike Pence or any vice
president for that matter has the
ability to Crown a king
it's really [__] dumb it's the
dumbest [__] idea I've ever heard in
my life that they really thought they
really thought that Mike Pence had the
power to Crown a king and the reason why
they thought that is because they didn't
really think it it was just their last
ditch effort it was like the last two
rods it was their last Hail Mary to get
Mike Pence to try this stupid [__] that
doesn't exist in our Constitution and
and vivec vivec loves that idea oh but
he hates the idea when you when you're
like well what about Kamala Harris what
about what about Joe Biden what about
Joe Vice President Joe Biden
certifying for Donald Trump what could
he just say [__] you [__] you we're
gonna make Hillary the president of the
United States that's your thought
process but if you don't believe that
then you don't believe that Mike Pence
had the power you [__] bonehead Vivek
again Vivek is a [__] [__] he
doesn't know anything but how to steal
people's money that's it period and he
knows how to appeal to Andrew Tate fans
so he knows how to steal your [__]
money which is part of the Andrew Tate
Universe how to steal your [__] money
when you're a [__] douchebag and sell
online but he knows how to steal your
[__] money and he knows how to appeal
to the Andrew Tate douchebags period
That's the two things Vivek knows
I might have an only hypothetical
because gambling is illegal in the state
of Texas
are we in the state are we in the state
of Texas right now or are we online I
know pool going on when Vivek ramaswamy
comes out and says that he did not say
that China and Russia have a military
Alliance even though he is set at 15
freaking times that China and Russia
have a military Alliance that we need to
focus on breaking up freaking [__] man
I mean he sits there and says uh you
know he thinks he's Donald Trump he
thinks he's Donald Trump he thinks he's
Donald Trump in 2016. not Donald Trump
today because and I'm going to tell you
because of me because of y'all because
we're up here doing this Donald Trump is
not the Donald Trump of 2016. and Vivek
ramaswami can't play that game where he
comes out and he says [__] and then
turns around two weeks later on
corporate [__] weak ass T corporate
media and says I didn't say that you're
misquoting me fake news you know I mean
[__] we've got you on we will dig
the damn video up and show you saying it
right out of your damn mouth Vivek I
mean I tell you what ramascarelli is
just
the other thing that that people need to
I mean I I don't think many people in
this chat if anyone at all are gonna buy
his book woke ink and read it but
if you read the books that he's written
and the one that he wrote in uh in
September of 2022 right and there's also
an interview he just did on Sunday like
he did it when it was with Dana Bash and
then he was also a Chuck Todd but on the
one with Chuck Todd Chuck Todd
pulled out the receipts he's like look
man in September 2022 your book came out
and you said several things one you call
Trump a sore loser two you talked about
Republicans finding now uh finding this
as a new strategy to say if we lose an
election then it was rigged it was
corrupt it was stolen it wasn't real or
legitimate but if they win then they
have no problem with it it's like we are
creating uh a a dangerous precedent here
where now if you win it's fine but if
you lose then you're going to be a sore
[__] loser and you're gonna have a
tantrum and You're Gonna Want to
complain and try to steal it back
and there were many other things that
were talked about January 6th as well as
transfer of power and now 11 months
later
you see I mean this is the very book
that he wrote this is his book he's gone
on the campaign talked about the book
He's advertising you see in the
background in certain Clips this is
something that he literally wrote
so these are his words so going to what
Texas ball said it's not only just video
the guy has books that he's written and
the most recent one from September 2022
shows him saying the complete opposite
of what he's done and you know Tony
mentioned earlier yes he received money
from a Soros fund but also Trump
received a loan from George Soros the
second thing is you've also got Vivek
ramaswamy making these bold claims about
his life that aren't true yesterday he
got served as cease and assist from
Eminem finally finally Republicans
destroyed the [__] destroy rap let me
let me point something out here because
I know his name's on the book but do we
really believe My Librarian I don't care
I don't care it doesn't matter he
totally had a Ghostwriter no because no
his words once he puts his name on it
they're his words
I'm sure he hired a ghost writer I don't
doubt it or someone to touch it up but
here's the thing his name's on the
[__] cup that's right instead those
are his words he's advertising his book
so guess what I'm gonna say it's your
book and if you come out and say I
didn't write the book even better why
because are you gonna give back all the
money that you defrauded the people who
bought the book I want go back to what
Texas Paul said about uh Russia and
China his his little thing where they're
like oh they're military Alliance and
and the craziest part about it is
here's his theory right okay think see
if you can pack this in a [__] this
10 pounds of [__] idea and do a two
pound sack okay
we're gonna try to pack it in there this
guy believes or he says he believes that
there's a big military alliance between
Russia and China right and then he says
in the same [__] breath that this is
the reason why Russia should be afforded
the 20 of Ukraine that they have taken
that it'll it'll make it'll make Russia
weaker with China somehow if they have a
military Alliance and somehow Russia
will not be military alliance with China
anymore because now they have 20 percent
of Ukraine that they stole their
Sovereign
that makes no sense like no one look
even if you don't know anything about
geopolitical the geopolitics of China
Russia Ukraine even if you don't know
much about it you you don't have to go
very far to like why the [__] would
Russia invading a sovereign country and
killing and murdering using war crimes
to kill their citizenry to take 20 of
their country why would Ukraine get
you know throwing up the white flag and
giving them 20 of the country what the
[__] on earth does that have to do with
weakening China
it only would if if what he says is true
that they have this big military
Alliance it would only strengthen China
you stupid bastards the only way that
China's weakened the only way that China
is weakened by the war in Ukraine is
when Russia loses period period
hello think McFly think did you know
there's a new DeLorean I don't mean to
skip topics like this if you if you I
just made it back to future reference
and I just boom if you saw the movie
Fast X you would know that there was no
like the New Deal wait are you [__]
kidding you you think I would go pay
money to watch Fast and Furious 30. hey
man look look look what if you're all
about the [__] fam then you can
respect that that movie's all about
family
[Laughter]
oh my God oh my God sorry I didn't mean
to get off topic go ahead Texas Paul
with Ukraine I got on the DeLorean which
I don't even know oh I know how I got
there think McFly think I pulled a line
from Back to the Future made me think of
it go ahead text fall tell us about tell
us about how you've listened to people
that are military experts I mean really
wait wait wait a second wait a second
you're assuming that vivek's gonna
listen to experts anywhere
yeah but our audience will
these people make a science out of war
and they do their damnedest to predict
where conflicts could break out in the
future and man a conflict on the Caspian
Sea between China and Russia is way high
on the top of the freaking list because
it was one of the richest oil fields in
the world and Russia dominates
and China is literally that far away
from it
feel free to go look at a map of Asia
folks you've got the Caspian Sea that is
literally what lost the Lost World War
II for Hitler Hitler's generals had had
he listened to his generals they would
have run south to the Caspian Sea and
Hitler said no I want to take Stalingrad
which is to the north
just north of you know if you look at a
map you can see it right you know I mean
if he'd gone to the Caspian Sea Russia
would have lost their oil fields and he
would have starved Russia to death and
this would have been a fascist [__]
world people
but no and and Russia's hitting there I
guarantee you hair freaking triggered
waiting for China to make a damn move
because I you know there is no freaking
Russia China military Alliance they
don't trust each other China doesn't
trust anybody they don't trust us and we
do billions upon billions of dollars of
business with them every freaking year
this guy is a [__] he is a complete and
utter [__] and Gabe is 100 right 100
right I promise you it will be a week or
two at the most that you'll get somebody
in a uniform with an education that will
say
Russia are not allies they are not
Military Allies and he will say I didn't
say that let me tell you what I really
miss what you're misquiting me you're
misquitting me no I didn't that's false
skirm is quoting me you're missing
you're misgarding me you're misloading
me there is a quote [__] I think it
was with Hannity and they're talking
about the China relationship the one
China policy which is funny because
Vivek Rama Swami benefited from his
relationship with China while he was
running pharmaceutical companies so just
gonna throw that out there but now that
he's running for president all of a
sudden he's like no no we can't support
China we need you know uh anyway so he
talks about
um microchip Independence saying that we
don't
need to rely and we shouldn't rely on
China for our microprocessors and our
microchips
now Shenzhen China is the Hub of where
all of this comes from
now if he's talking about independence
from China specifically on the
fabrication of microprocessors and chips
it's almost like he's out for he's
advocating for something that was passed
under Joe Biden why Independence wait
wait wait wait wait are you saying are
you saying he likes the Democratic
party's policy I'm not saying that well
he hasn't officially you know we can't
quote him but I can infer that if he's
if he's talking about independence from
China on the manufacturing or
fabrication of processors and chips
that it almost seems intuitive to to
believe that he would be in support of
this America First policy where we
develop
ships here
in the United States are you talking
like potato chips or computer chips
because well I'm getting hungry here
both but mainly computer chips good good
so when he talks about that
I I feel like everyone whenever you hear
him say that you should challenge him
and say great I'm glad you support uh
Joe Biden's chip out you chips Act is
great I'm glad you love it I'm glad you
support it it's bringing jobs to America
it's allowing us to be independent it's
allowing us to build
infrastructure around an industry that
we don't really have right now because
we have it isolated in some markets in
the country but it's more expensive
because it's a specialized skill and we
don't have the same type of factories
and machines and scalability that they
do in Shenzhen and other areas in China
so whenever he says something like oh
yeah no America no China first policy we
have to have chip Independence say great
I'm glad you support Joe Biden's chips
act right well speaking of computer
chips I want to show the audience here
the new DeLorean
um I know it just doesn't have anything
to do with what just what I want to talk
about my [__] show I can talk about
what I want to talk about this pretty
cool [__] car I'm not gonna lie I
like the movie The delore story in the
actual old DeLorean the car was
absolutely [__] I have a neighbor yeah
down the street does he have one he has
one and every summer he'll bring it out
is it a DeLorean or is it the Back to
the Future DeLorean no it's well it's a
DeLorean and he's retrofitted it to be a
baby okay because because you know
there's some people that have The
Deloreans and then there's some movies I
don't know who would ever because here's
the thing he only brings it out for like
two or three months in the summer yeah
so he can drive around there's always a
parade there's different shows and stuff
yeah there's different clubs and stuff
the car is notorious for breaking down
it is it's it is incredibly slow it's it
was advertised as a luxury vehicle if
anyone doesn't know the back story the
whole cocaine FBI thing in terms of oh
[__] it's fantastic what a great story
honest honestly I am so happy that
that's what the story of the car is a
lot of people in the Discord are saying
I'm stuck on the DeLorean yeah I am I
have been since I watched this [__]
video this morning the only thing I'm
I'm not uh that's a beautiful car it is
the front lights up it's it's really
cool oh you'll see it in the video the
problem is is this doesn't have a flux
and it's within reach for like you know
your your your I'd say about 85 90 of
the country I should say the top 85 to
90 percent I mean it's not a
middle-class car by any means but the
very scrape and top of the middle class
it's 150 000 folks I mean it's it's not
like 1.5 million dollars or anything
like that
it's a badass car but again my one knock
is is that it doesn't
it doesn't have a flush capacitor but it
gets pretty close watch the DeLorean is
back when you swipe
right bars go on go into these lights
the same like design the lights on the
back
there we go look at that here on the
screen you now get the option of updated
gauge back to the 80s baby DeLorean
wristbands
send you a hug and the chair actually
will hug you also it syncs with your
phone's contacts show the car quit
focusing on Blondie hey your friends
this car will give you a hug I wonder if
it gives hand jobs to you I don't know I
don't know I have no there's a there's a
part of me that was like oh this is like
a this could be totally modified to be a
sex toy but then the other one's like
this could also be modified to kill you
like it's like I love you so much are we
gonna just squeezes around and then you
die I think we're at zero days now with
this uh with the sex toy sex toy
DeLorean time I mean she put it out
there with suggesting that you feel the
heartbeat you know right it's like there
already are sex toys that allow you to
use them remotely with your with your
phone
we don't want to get in too many rabbit
holes today so let's uh let's take it
easy on what kind of uh devices are are
exist out there the hiking feature
though the hugging feature does make me
well sure but it also makes me think
that like one malfunction and they'd be
like another another customer died from
being suffocated by hugging
I think this is pretty cool though it's
a pretty cool car it looks pretty sweet
um again I I don't know if I'd pay 150
000 for it I want to it is a DeLorean so
you gotta wait to see like how shitty
they really are I mean DeLorean other
than the Back to the Future movie that's
the only reason why we know what it is
anyways yeah
um did you know do you know a quick fact
do you know that they had to change the
speedometer
on on the actual car because it wouldn't
go so they had to pick 88 because it I
think at the time it was there was a
regulation it was like 85 was the max it
could go that was the a governor it was
a it was a it was a policy in place and
I'm trying to remember
um
let me see I think it was 85 miles an
hour and so they had to change it
it was chosen okay yeah 1979 a law
passed by then President Jimmy Carter
had limited speedometers to 85 miles per
hour to reduce speeding and so
when they created it they were they had
chosen 88 as the travel speed because it
was easy to remember and also looked
cool on the speedometer so when they're
like you got to go to 88 you know that
was the whole thing but at the time
speedometers were limited to 85 as a
means of psychologically right mentally
trying to
trick people to think like oh you can't
go past 85 right 88 miles an hour
that's the famous you know something a
little cool about this car actually is
it's uh it's a Texas car
oh unreal yeah yeah yeah the guy that
when DeLorean tanked uh uh
a guy that owns some shops down here in
Texas bought up the rights to it and all
the old parts so he could sell people
that still had DeLorean Sparks
um and uh yeah he's the one that that
actually this is this is a Houston Texas
car
look at that homegrown man yeah boom
homegrown in Texas
damn well I don't know if it's still a
piece of [__] like the original one I
think it had a the original had like a
Chevy 305 in it it was it was originally
built to be a cop car in Europe but it
was such a dog it was so freaking slow
because it was made out of stainless
freaking steel weighed as much as a
freaking tank had like 180 horsepower I
mean it was I know my numbers are wrong
here but it had like a Chevy 305 in it
that was just notorious for being a
shittily shitty underpowered engine
um and you know it couldn't perform as
as a that's a police car so he ended up
selling it to to people he'd
that thought it was cool I mean they
just and the worst part about it was it
has a foam bumper on the front and over
time that foam bumper turns brittle and
shrinks and you and and looks like
hammered yeah yeah I mean you really had
that's the reason your neighbor only
takes one out every once in a while yeah
you expose it to the sun your car shrink
it looks like [__] well if if no one's
aware uh John DeLorean is one of the
fathers of the muscle car area era in
this country
um and also he tried to save his car
company DeLorean by doing a cocaine deal
it's a wild it's a wild story I think
there's there's two movies that are made
one is with Jason Sudeikis yes and uh
and I think it's the other one is Alec
Baldwin but it's like a the one with
Alec Bolton it's like a docu series yeah
yeah the one with Jason Sudeikis and Lee
Pace is a a comedy right
um I guess I could draw money like
serious moments in it but it's dramedy
andromedy yeah it is very
um
very funny I think yeah well crazy story
that I had no idea about it I didn't I
didn't know the cocaine thing about uh
John DeLorean we've got a we've got a
venmo super chat here uh from the coal
you two are some of the funniest or you
are some of the most truthful
[__] out there right now uh
thank you very much for the uh the venmo
Super Chat there Nicole if you want to
do a venmo super chat go to the Tony
michaels.com you can see the link at the
top uh also if you go to the Tony
michaels.com you can find the current
episode at the top and you'll find this
you'll find a
the thumbnail that I made this morning
that's right this one's mine this one's
not Gabe's I'm taking credit for it
that's fine all you
hey all the other ones are game this
morning but I I wanna I wanna point this
out because of his uh because of his
statement this morning
um he's throwing [__] around on on fraud
social here here's the statement here he
says these indictments and lawsuits are
all part of my political opponent's
campaign plan it is election
interference no you committed election
interference that's why you're being
prosecuted and they are going to use the
doj FBI to help them which is illegal I
don't know what the hell is illegal
about the doj and FBI uh Prosecuting
criminals but you know go on he says
crooked Joe pushed this litigation hard
to get it done this is a new low in
presidential politics coming from the
actual lowest up Below in presidential
politics I made he goes on to threaten
he says to the Democrats I say quote
vote he put it in quote be careful what
you wish for
Texas Palm
it really seems he's trying desperately
desperately to get a prosecutor anywhere
who has the guts to try to prosecute the
lies against Joe Biden that's what it
feels like to me and that's what he
wants is a County prosecutor somewhere
who's a [__] idiot to try to
prosecute the absolute non-crimes that
they have evidence for for Joe Biden I
actually hope yeah
he knows that won't fly though because
actually in a court you have to present
prevent things like evidence
um and you and and any D.A knows that
it's actually a crime for them to do
that they will get themselves their
their their Department whatever
municipality or or whatever pull their
[__] license yeah it'll pull their
ticket and then they will get sued out
into Oblivion
um but no but what is going to happen is
the Republicans are going to and and
Kevin McCarthy said they're going to do
this they're going to run a a parallel
impeachment
to Trump's trial
that's what they're going to do
[Laughter]
Trump
I mean I already see writing
riding on the government next month
here's what they're going to do they're
already talking about this stupid [__]
um here let me let me show you a tweet
from uh this uh Trader Derek Evans he's
running for congress he's an
insurrectionist he's a January 6th or
that went to went to [__] prison for
it
um and he he continues to [__]
threaten people in this country but
they're already talking about they're
going to shut down the government in
September here's what they're going to
do this is all the talk online it's
going to be the Democrats are locking
down the country that is how they're
going to sell this shutdown is the
Democrats are locking down the country
uh listen here's what Derek he asked
this question this morning and I
answered him a few times with a question
but here's his are you going to wear a
mask if the government tells you to
um now there may be cause for someone to
get concerned about wearing a mask like
yeah you know there's a certain reasons
why people would maybe you you just
don't want to catch covid maybe you want
to prevent it maybe you have autoimmune
disorder maybe you have Covenant you
want to give it to someone else there's
all kinds of maybe you got the [__]
flu
or a cough and you don't want to give
someone else the [__] sickness that
you got
but here's a couple of my responses to
uh to the trader Derrick Evans this
morning I said are you going to wear are
you going to wear clothes that the
government tells you to
are you gonna do that Derek he didn't
answer me on that one let's see maybe
maybe he answered me on this one uh
probably not let's see here's this one
uh are you going to marry who the
government tells you to hmm I wonder I
wonder if he's going to do that oh
here's another good one here's another
good one
um that Derek could answer are you going
to practice the religion the government
tells you to hmm I wonder if he's gonna
do that I wonder if he's I don't know if
he's against government when it talks
about that here's a popular one here's a
popular question I posed this morning to
the trader Derek Evans I said are you
going to burn the books the government
tells you to Derek huh I don't know I
don't know again I I probably keep going
here maybe maybe that maybe this one
will help Derek maybe this will help him
are you going to receive only receive
the health care that the government
tells you to Derek are you going to do
that these people are so [__] dumb
this is the dumbest [__] I've ever heard
of in my life and this is what they're
gonna do their plan is to shut down the
government blame it on lockdowns and and
it's going to backfire magnificently it
really really will but Texas Paul if
you're right if you're right that
they're going to try to impeach Joe
Biden do it do it man [__] do it the
reason why they haven't already done it
is because Kevin McCarthy and the rest
of Republicans know if they bring that
to the floor of the house it will fail
it will fail miserably on the house
floor there's no way even with
Republican majority the slim majority
they have there is no way they vote to
impeach Joe Biden they won't do it they
won't do it well I was I was uh I was
out last night with a friend and we were
taught talking about this incessant
desire that Republicans have to impeach
Joe Biden and he was like how many times
have they tried to impeach Joe Biden
this year and I go dude I honestly I've
lost count I think it's more than 10. it
could be nine but like when you're 27.
yeah it honestly could be that meant it
could be three times what I was just
saying like it's one of those things
where when you realize
you've got people and this is how you
know they're not serious for there's a
couple reasons but the main one is when
you have two people specifically
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
fighting on the house floor to do the
same thing
they're they're trying to do the same
thing they're trying to impeach Joe
Biden when you have two people from the
Republican Party fighting over who gets
credit
and who votes for who's
impeachment
you have to understand and realize that
these are not serious people who
actually want to impeach Joe Biden on
actual merits they're they're there to
clout Chase they're there to take credit
to be oh look I was the one who took
down Joe Biden it's not actually that
they they really care about the mayor of
the law it's not like stewby who goes to
Iowa on Trump on team Trump and says
yesterday I introduced articles of
impeachment against Joe Biden and he's
like oh drugs money prostitution said it
again on the show before great I'm glad
that you identified the crimes that
Donald Trump is guilty of let's talk
about Joe Biden because at the end of
the day you have nothing
and when the House Republicans admit
anonymously but also other people like
Comer and Jordan have been like well we
hope to find evidence well we don't have
any evidence then it goes to a point of
well actually right now we don't
actually need evidence
and now yesterday it's been reported the
House Republicans are admitting just
openly now admitting to the fact that
they they do they have no evidence they
don't have a say they have to shred of
evidence they have to here's the reason
why Gabe they have to admit they have no
evidence because they have to convince
their base that they're gonna have to
convince their base that they can that
they can impeach Joe Biden well Hunter
Biden they can impeach Hunter Biden with
no evidence they have to convince them
of that and it's a slow walk to this
idea that we don't care if there's no
evidence just a beach Hunter Biden
already like that's literally and
speaking of Jim Jordan um the good liars
ran into Jim Jordan apparently I think
that's who this is I think that's who
this is let's take a listen to see what
uh it looked maybe this is Jim Jordan's
dad maybe it's his dad I don't know if
it's him let's listen what were they
chanting at the rallies I think we all
remember they had some pretty good
chance no just the the usual uh you know
USA uh
make America great again lock her up
lock her up
the obvious things yeah I mean yeah
um what do you think in general about
jailing political opponents totally
against it is against the Constitution
it's it's not America it's not the US
I mean I mean think about it okay so so
I feel like we're talking about two
different things I was talking about
when Trump was trying to get Hillary in
jail in In 2016. oh I see what you mean
oh
oh yeah and and like yeah you thought I
was joking when I was talking about Jim
Jordan literally this this is who Jim
Jordan is using they're using these
[__] frail-minded people who had this
frail-minded logic yeah um where they're
like yeah jail your political opponent
like Trump's saying this morning be
careful what you wish for because we're
gonna prosecute we're gonna throw you in
jail with no due process that's
literally what he's saying can you can
you two tell me if you impeach Hunter
Biden's dick yeah does it also transfer
to Hunter Biden being totally impeached
as well as or just his dick it's just
his dick oh okay all right and yeah
actually if you want if you want to
impeach his balls because if you don't
impeach if you just a peaches dick and
not his sack yeah then the sack become
because the sack is like the vice
president of the of the male genital
right yeah so like that the president
obviously gets all the rewards that the
shaft gets all the rewards but the vice
president does a lot out of the work but
gets really none of the credit most the
time right I mean it gets none of the
credits sometimes it gets attention
right sometimes you know it might it
gets attention sometimes but I think if
you impeach Hunter Biden's dick
I believe his balls then become the
president so it really
um we still had the situation where
Hunter Biden's genitalia is still in the
political process here
speaking of Hunter Biden
or yeah I have Hunter Biden or Hunter
Biden's dick because there might be a
difference no actually actually speaking
of Hunter Biden actually speaking of
maggots and Hunter Biden yeah if you
find someone that says it a maggot that
says that this is just political
persecution that it is just a
prosecution of your political enemy and
you go to their social media
it is a guaranteed 100 fact
physics of the universe that there will
be a tweet or a Facebook post or
something celebrating the fact that
Hunter Biden's
plea deal fell through and they are now
going to prosecute Hunter Biden
these same people that are crying you
can't prosecute political enemy are
literally celebrating that they're
Prosecuting the child of their political
enemy
well I mean
and his dick I am and his dick because
that's really what they want to that's
really what they want to prosecute I got
another venmo Super Chat here and it's
from Rico on Discord
um it took less than three months
from the whistleblowers allegations for
the Democrats to impeach him over the
phone call
Republicans are too incompetent to get
it done so um Rico here is suggesting
that the Republicans will not be able to
impeach Joe Biden I tend to believe Rico
that that they will not be able to
impeach Joe Biden Hunter Biden's dick
maybe a different story but here's the
thing I actually want them to bring this
to the floor Rico that is what I want
them to do and the reason why is because
it will fail on the floor that's why
they haven't already brought this well
no no no okay we have to remember they
did bring Lauren boberts to the floor
and you have to remember what Kevin
McCarthy did he pushed it over to Jim
Jordan right in the oversight because he
was like I don't want to deal with this
because it's a losing battle if we lose
it on camera in front of everyone right
it's not gonna look great
so they won the vote to push it to
committee on the floor
yeah sure yeah yeah sure we'll we'll
impeach we'll impeach Hunter Biden's
dick and that will remove that will
remove Joe Biden somehow and leave
that's the other thing too is I watched
a video the other day Donald Trump came
out on Donald Trump came out on Truth
social and he screamed that they
impeached me twice and indicted me four
times and I demand that you Republicans
grow a spine and take action now now and
Kevin McCarthy didn't walk he literally
ran and was out of breath when he got to
the microphone and said yes daddy yes
daddy that's what we're going to do I
promise you and he came out yesterday I
think it was yesterday he came out maybe
maybe the day before he no it was
yesterday he walked up to the microphone
and said impeachment is the natural
progression of what we are doing here in
the house
that is what we're going to do yeah
because daddy said so do it do it
do it do it I listen I actually believe
that them trying to actually impeach Joe
Biden would be would would be would be
better for uh the country than what you
think it really true because I'm telling
you they're going to shut down the
government next month they're gonna do
it and they're gonna say it's coveted
lockdowns that's what because they're
already already I want to point out uh
Marcia Jones they didn't indict him yeah
that indicated him they did they did
they did indicate him four times but we
have to remember too that they're
already starting Byron Donald's already
got [__] fact checked on Twitter I
don't know if you showed that tweet but
he's trying to give it to me give it to
me in a few minutes basically Byron
McDonalds is trying to uh
let's do that and trying to blame the
lockdowns for or on on Joe Biden what
lockdowns what lockdowns you mean the
ones from 2020. oh really you know
that's kind of funny who was the
president 2020 who was it I don't know
dude it's like uh man I don't I think
he's running again what really um yeah
it's uh wait you're saying you're saying
that Joe Biden had no control in the
country in 2020 man is that what you're
doing Joe Biden it feels like there's a
vanilla ice cream eaten Puppeteer man
from a basement okay that guy can do
whatever he wants he can control gas
inflation
you know where was he where was he you
know was he out golfing I don't know you
know I mean why why did how did Obama
let 9 11 happen do you say that and if
you wonder why I'm saying that video
there's a real video there's a real
[__] video of a guy saying that [__]
and like uh he was in the state senate
right I don't know what he was done he
wasn't in he wasn't even Senator yet
that guy ain't alone you ask anybody who
is responsible for the failures of 9 11
and they will tell you it was Barack
Hussein Obama
I'm done because he was looking for his
birth certificate
I'm just kidding instead of being
president like he was supposed to be
just kidding I'm not going to go
anywhere here's here's Byron Donald's
we're gonna drag him for a few minutes
before we go
um Byron United says reminder here's a
reminder of the lie that I'm gonna tell
here in just a second uh on my Twitter
account Byron Donald says it says
reminder Joe Biden and his party
shuttered schools
forced mask on their faces okay and put
vaccines in their arms all while holding
our children back not even the children
yeah well I have long lasting impacts on
their educational future Joe Biden to
Democrats put power over our kids
oh my God Byron knowledge you are a dumb
[__] man you are the dumbest
[__] and yeah go ahead Texas
fall
I don't lie I I won't lie
yes Joe Biden was responsible for the
fact that your child could get a vaccine
because Donald Trump was a cluster
[__] idiot who could not get vials he
couldn't get needles he couldn't get any
of it done the production was
straightened out under Joe Biden and the
the the the the the vaccines that saved
tens of millions of lives
was brought to you by Joe Biden you want
me you want me to fact check you because
um I get your narrative there but the
narrative should be that that Donald
Trump is the one who got the vaccines
you know why the the go back to that
tweet go back to that tweet do you know
why do you know why the original
do you know why with this one here yeah
yeah scroll down keep going keep going
oh here we go
whoa not that Elon Musk community no
it's guys no so so here's the thing
here's the thing is that
is that Donald Trump the reason why the
vaccine roll out went over like a wet
fart and white thong under Donald Trump
is because he was so concentrated he had
no time to save Americans lives he only
wanted to save his own power that's it
if he would have listened if he would
have said after Joe Biden was announced
the winner and it was clearly's winner
if Donald Trump would have came out and
said you know what I can see it he won
but you know what I'm gonna do is my
last effort as president of the United
States I'm gonna make sure as many
people in this country get vaccinated as
possible
to save lives and if he would have put
all his effort that he tried to overturn
our election
into deploying the vaccines in this
country
we would have saved more lives we would
have saved more lives and and he
wouldn't be indicted today I believe
that he wouldn't have been indicted and
the reason why is because he wouldn't
try to overturn the election yeah he
wouldn't have stole a bunch of [__]
documents that didn't belong to him and
likely the Manhattan DA's office would
have been like you know what I'm just
we're just gonna he's done he's gone
we're done we're done with Donald Trump
for history we're just gonna let it set
aside [__] wouldn't be indicted
so if the truth is the truth is the
truth if Donald Trump would have done
his [__] duty and to his oath then
Duty then there would be but here's the
comedian that says all 50 states
governed by both
majority parties closed schools in 2020
10 months before Biden assumed office by
March 25th 2020 all public schools in
the U.S were closed that was within 10
days of a national announcement being
made about covid and saying we need to
lock down
social distancing make sure you limit
your contact with other people I mean
look at the end of the day it was the
most basic
kind of we'll call them guidelines not
even rules
guidelines to follow hey there's a novel
virus it's it's its first form and we're
seeing these are the effects that people
are having we've got ERS that are being
overrun elderly and uh immunocompromised
people are being targeted specifically
because they don't have the immune
system so fight them we need to make
sure that we don't have contact with
other people family friends I know it's
difficult but if you can just do me this
solid and at the time they're like two
weeks that's all it'll take two weeks
obviously it was much longer than that
but you had Republicans who are like
[__] this [__] they probably took it
seriously I want to say for maybe the
first seven days and like well I didn't
catch covet yet so I'm not going to
catch it ever then you had people having
the [__] biker gang parade and
Sturgis okay that was a crazy super
spreader you had the Supreme Court
nomination event that happened at the
White House that was another Super
spreader when you look at these events
that happened
and not only the not only that but also
the the people that were recommending
non-approved drugs to treat covid
where people in the Republican party man
you better take that Ivermectin that's
not no dude okay your worms won't have
coats like [__] what what I mean I mean
you won't have worms you might have yeah
or the kova that's in your body will be
dewormed but you won't have like you'll
still have covid
and then it's it's it comes down to
go ahead Republicans don't like science
and facts and they always want to be
right and it's confirmation bias it's
Dunning cougar effect it's uh Echo
chamber it's
um cognitive dissonance I mean really
really did expose itself during covid
but when when Republicans now are trying
to reformat or or uh do their
revisionist storytelling
they can't because they were the ones in
power and they were the ones doing this
and they were the ones that dropped the
ball and [__] up Joe Biden like Texas
Paul said came in and picked it up like
an adult and said [__] okay we gotta
pick up the toys off the ground yeah all
kinds of messes
in the vaccine roll out because Donald
Trump was so focused on stealing our
[__] election away from us that he
had to clean up all kinds of other [__]
Texas Paul was there one last thought
you were gonna give here
I was just thinking about I was
listening to to Gabe and it was just
bringing back memories and I just the
number of people in my area that ran
down to the feed store and bought horse
strength Ivermectin whose dosages are
meant for a creature that weighs a
thousand [__] pounds and all muscle
but all muscle yeah plus and took those
[__] Doses and [__] their intestinal
Linings out
I'm happy for him if you want to know
the honest truth so let me tell you a
couple little stories here real quick
before we leave I know we're overtime I
want to say happy birthday to Andy
travels uh Andy Andy a happy birthday to
you happy birthday to you you everyone
wish Andy happy birthday but here's
here's the um the other thing I want to
say I talked to a vet a veterinarian
um during that time period I thought you
said you'd I talked to vivec and I was
like whoa dude no no a vet oh a vet okay
a veterinarian okay now I didn't I
didn't I wasn't like hey how how much do
I take what he said was is he's like
look they're veterinarians were having
conference calls all around the country
because people were going to Tractor
Supply type stores and buying this [__]
off the shelves so much so that they
were taken at Tractor Supply and [__]
was taking it off the shelves because
they knew people were buying it to to
[__] take it themselves not give it
to their goddamn livestock so what was
happening was is then they would go into
a vet a veterinarian's office because
you could buy it at the the tractor
supply store or or the feed supply store
or you could go to a veterinarian's
office where they you know the
veterinarians for for bigger animals
horses cattle sheep that sort of thing
there's some veterinarians that just you
smiling almost cats and dogs and some
that do farm animals but they would go
into the farm vets and they would be
like hey I want some horse space and
they're like no they were having
conference calls all around the country
to try to explain for the veterinarians
to explain to human beings coming and
wanting to take this [__] for coven what
the [__] it would do to them if they
took it like no no you don't want to
take this [__] I've ever met this type
of ivermectin is dosed and designed for
animals for livestock there is an
Ivermectin pill and it's only FDA
approved for a certain worm that you get
in uh Africa because it's a dewormer
like that's the craziest part is like oh
I ever reckons FDA approved well why all
of a sudden now do you believe in the
FDA yeah but here's the thing folks this
stupidity continues because they're
going to talk about lockdowns that don't
exist and haven't existed I'll give you
an example here in Missouri
our governor shut down the state of
Missouri from about the end of March
until the beginning of may we haven't
had a [__] government sanctioned
lockdown in Missouri
since May of 2020 folks not one lockdown
not one [__] mandate has been in
place since May of 2020 a long time ago
a long time ago so I just want to put
that in perspective when they talk about
this government shutdown is the
government lockdown and that they're
going to try to make you wear masks and
all this kind of stuff and you should
wear a mask if you're sick or if you're
around sick people you should wear a
[__] mess don't get people sick be
safe don't get sick yourself if you can
help but do that go get vaccinated I
don't care if it's covet or or the flu
shot or whatever it is be safe be
healthy do that and what else also you
should do is go to realtexaspaul.com
that's realtexasball.com he's got a show
on tomorrow on Wednesdays and Sunday now
Texas Paul thanks for joining us here
also absolutely absolutely do not forget
to subscribe as you're leaving the Tony
Michaels podcast here on YouTube and
what you can do is go to the Tony
michaels.com I'm directing you to go to
the Tony Michael dot com follow us
everywhere go look at Gabe's stuff uh
send us a venmo chat if you want thank
you for the venmo chats today go get
into the Discord where the chat never
stops the link is over there we're gonna
have a uh smash the flash art contest
people have already been submitting
we're going to release the rules really
soon so keep submitting your ideas over
on the Discord to submit your ID on the
Discord just go to the attorney
michaels.com there's a link there right
now that takes you directly to the
Discord and they will direct you where
to go to submit your your idea for smash
the flash artwork so do that we're going
to be voting on that very soon we'll
have the rules out very soon Gabe do you
have any last words before we go uh I
mean I gotta what was that that I just
released should be going public probably
later today I got another what was that
I'm going to be dragging Vivek Rama
Swami and I'll probably be going over
the infatuation that Republicans have on
Donald Trump's mug shot and the crazy
things that they're saying about it so
go to patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez
that's patreon.com you can also go to
the Tony michaels.com Gabe's link is
down below Gabe merch store click that
it'll go to his link tree go to Texas
Paul swing tree just go to
realtexaspaul.com that's
realtexaspaul.com follow him everywhere
and don't forget to be here tomorrow
we're going to talk about tennis to
Tennessee Brando tomorrow tomorrow
Tennessee Brando at the bottom of the
hour about this Oliver Anthony [__] all
the new updates on it I'm going to talk
to him tomorrow same time same place
Surfs Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon
anybody took a Pfizer is owned by Pfizer
anybody taking moderna is owned by
moderna and they're calling the species
Borg Genesis it's not even human anymore
it's called board Genesis it's not even
human the people who took the vaccine
they're not considered human anymore
wait the people who got the vaccine are
no longer human no and they're actually
owned they're enslaved by Pfizer or
modern or whoever they took the shot
from so they're public they're their
property people who took the vaccine are
owned by Pfizer now and are not human
Medics has changed so they're not human
anymore so they're a boric Genesis
that's owned by Pfizer or their
borgenesis that's owned by and there you
have it we are in Laguna Hills talking
to people apparently if you've taken the
vaccine you are no longer human
resistance is futile